The survey that the post office has published
on the elections
Basque has left
several conclusions
very much to be taken into account.
First,
that the battle between the PNV and h.
Bildu is going to be tough.
There is a technical tie
and at this stage of the game,
Victory in seat will be 1 coin in the air.
It doesn't matter who wins,
since the important thing will be who will govern.
And here
the match that will decide the tie-breaker is called the match
socialist of the Basque Country.
But the most striking aspect of the survey is the effect
Gorrochategui,
the unknown ignorance
that the Basque society
has of the candidates he has to choose.
Look,
Gorrochategui is by far the best known,
but among those who know it,
few know that it is presented by "we can"
only 1 37%.
But it's not left here,
1 15% believe they do it for the PNV and 1 10% for Bildu.
Something similar happens with Peyo Chandiano,
the brand new head of the list by e.
H. Bildu.
When you ask by this name,
more than half of the respondents
it doesn't ring a bell
and among those who know him,
only 1 59% associate him with Bildu and the rest,
1 10% to the PNV and 1 30%.
To add up,
the Basques' lack of knowledge of their leaders
politicians is something so striking
as governor,
something we should all reflect on